on the airport tarmac a lifeless looking
alexei navalny is wheeled into a waiting
ambulance
his fellow passengers witnesses to a
horrible episode
which his campaign staff claim was a
deliberate poisoning
from the cup of tea he had in the
airport
these his groans as emergency staff made
their way through the plane
just before he lost consciousness in the
toilet he's now in a coma
and on a ventilator in the siberian city
of omsk
stable but too sick to be moved his
doctors say
as the hospital swarms with police and
his team
beg for him to be transferred
few tread a more dangerous path in
russia than alexei navalny
he is the most prominent and outspoken
of the kremlin's critics
and his forensic youtube exposes of
high-level corruption
have racked up millions of views and won
him enemies across the political and
corporate spheres
he has spent years in and out of
detention and suffered attacks before
one of which permanently damaged the
site in one eye
but if this is a poisoning it marks the
most dangerous attempt on his life so
far
one that he may still survive as piotr
versilov of activist group riot
did
after emergency treatment in berlin but
which
other kremlin foes most famously
alexander litvinyenko
have not both myself and navalny were
active members of the russian opposition
and we are sure that the only people
that have the capability
to target uh navalny or myself are
russian security services with definite
clear uh with definite
uh clearance from russia's political
leadership
the question of clearance from the top
is a never-ending one
and in the murkiness of russian politics
there may never be clear answers about
who is directly responsible
but even now navalny's fragile condition
is a stain on the conscience of the
russian state
dinah magnay sky news